في بدايه اعتقالي الاول
في شكل من اشكال المناوره على التحقيق
ولكي اكسب الوقت واعطي فرصه
لرفاقي بحيث يتداركوا امر اعتقالي ادعيت
اشياء غير صحيحه وقلت انه انا ساكن بحمص
انا اعتقلت بحلب فقلت له انا ساكن بحمص
فهنا اخذوا اجراءاتهم وشكلوا دوريه وجابوا
سياره وكذا وبعتوني على حمص على اساس
بحمص وصلنا بحمص بالليل ما في مجال هذا
اخذوني على سجن اسمه السجن البالوني فنمت
بسجن البالوني هذا مثلا
خلينا نقول استثناء انك تروح على السجن
البالوني وتعيش فيه مثلا لمده يوم او
يومين وبعدين ترجع اثناء النقل مثلا من
سجن الى سجن شكله طبيعي احيانا هن بينقلوك
بدون ما يكون في سبب يعني
بعد ما تحس فيه نوع من التنافس بين هذه
الجهات الامنيه لارضاء راس النظام طبعا في
دائما التنافس هو لحد الان في تنافس بين
سوريا في العديد من الاجهزه والاجهزه
والجهاد الامنيه يعني ودائما في تنافس
بيناتهم يعني ودائما في تكتم بمعلومات
تجاه الاخرين يعني يعني الامن السياسي ما
بيعطي معلوماته للامن العسكري والامن
العسكري ما بيعطي معلوماته لامن الدوله
وهكذا يعني